.
SENDING IT BACK TO YOU.
>> ONCE AGAIN, GREAT JOB
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NOT AS YOU MAY HAVE HEARD
PRESIDENT BIDEN TOLD HIM THIS
WEEK THAT HE WAS NOT MAKING A
STOP TO THE BORDER BECAUSE THEY
WERE "MORE IMPORTANT THINGS
GOING ON" BUT WHILE THE BORDER
MAY NOT BE A PERSON A PRIORITY
FOR THIS PRESIDENT, HIS
ADMINISTRATION IS NOW SEEKING
MORE FUNDING AND ASKING CONGRESS
FOR $3 BILLION TO HELP DEAL WITH
THEIR SELF-INFLICTED BORDER
CRISIS.
A QUITE AS THAT IS EXPECTED ONLY
GET WORSE ONCE THE TITLE 42
BORDER PROTECTIONS ARE FIRMLY
LIFTED.
HERE NOW WITH THAT REACTION IS
OUR FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR
SARA CARTER, WHO HAS BEEN ON
THIS ISSUE FROM THE START.
AND THE PRESIDENT OF THE
NATIONAL BORDER PATROL COUNCIL,
BRANDON JUDD.
BRANDON, LET ME START WITH YOU.
WE SAW THE FOOTAGE, REMARKABLE
WORK BY LAW ENFORCEMENT ON THE
GROUND THERE, BUT WITH TEXAS,
AND GET QUEST WE STILL NOTE THAT
AS BILL NOTED WE ARE
UNDERSTAFFED.
AND THE RESOURCES YOU GUYS NEED
YOU DON'T HAVE.
AND NOW YOU GOT PEOPLE COMING IN
WITH THAT'S FULL OF AMMUNITION.
HOW DO YOU SEE THIS IS STILL
FULL NAME, OR UNFOLDING WHEN IT
COMES TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
LEARNING ABOUT ALL OF THIS, WHAT
ARE YOU TRYING TO GET THIS POINT
TO SLOW THIS DOWN FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION?
>> I'M ABSOLUTELY DISGUSTED
THAT THEY HAVE TO DO MY JOB.
THAT WE DO NOT HAVE ENOUGH
AGENTS IN THAT AREA TO ACTUALLY
INTERDICT THESE PEOPLE BEFORE
TEXAS DPS HAS TO GET TO VEHICLE
CASES LIKE THIS.
IF WE HAD THE RESOURCES THAT
WERE NECESSARY IN THE PROPER
POLICIES AND PROGRAMS THAT WERE
NECESSARY WE COULD DO THE JOB IN
SECURING THE BORDER AND PROTECT
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
AND THUS NOT WHAT BE AT THE
HEART, WHAT'S INTERESTING IS
THAT IT DOES NOT COST THE
AMERICAN TAXPAYER HAD TIME TO
HAVE PROPER POLICIES AND
PROGRAMS IN PLACE.
HE COMPLETELY, GUTTED EVERYTHING
THAT WE WERE ABLE TO ACCOMPLISH
UNDER PRESIDENT TRUMP SIMPLY
BECAUSE HE WANTS TO APPEASE HIS
FAR LEFT BASE.
AND THAT DOES NOT SERVE THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
AND AGAIN, THAT IS MUCH US TO
SEE WHAT HE IS CURRENTLY DONE TO
THE BORDER SITUATION.
AND NOT GIVING US A PROPER
POLICIES AND PROGRAMS THAT ARE
NECESSARY.
>> IT'S INTERESTING BECAUSE
THEY WANT $3 BILLION AND THAT'S
A LOT OF MONEY.
BUT THEN NOT SAYING WHAT THEY
GONNA DO WITH IT AND THE
REPUBLICANS DON'T WANT TO GIVE
IT A UNDERSTANDABLY THE BORDER
IS CLOSED.
WHICH IS SEEMS LIKE THAT IS
NEVER GOING TO HAPPEN.
DO YOU THINK THAT MONEY, WOULD
GO TO MORE BORDER PATROL AGENTS?
AND WOULD DO TO SECURITY?
>> NO ABSOLUTELY NOT THAT
MONEY IS JUST GONNA GO TO TO
FACILITATE MORE PEOPLE TO GET
RELEASED INTO THE UNITED STATES
QUICKER.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE TOTAL
NUMBERS, WE ARE VERY READY
RELEASE CLOSE TO 4 MILLION
PEOPLE INTO THE UNITED STATES
AND THEN ON TOP OF THAT WITH HAD
MORE THAN A MILLION GOT A WAYS
INTO THE UNITED STATES.
ALWAYS TRYING TO DO IS PROCESS
AND FACILITATE THE RELEASE OF
PEOPLE EVEN QUICKER.
>> SARAH, I HEAR YOU AGREEING
OVER THERE AND IT IS OBVIOUS
THAT THIS IS ABOUT -- MAYBE IT'S
BUYING MORE HOTEL ROOMS.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THEY WANT TO
DO WITH THE 3 BILLION BUT IS NOT
ABOUT SECURING THE COUNTRY.
>> NO, IT ISN'T.
IT IS ENTIRELY AND THIS IS ABOUT
A NIGHTMARE SCENARIO THAT IS NOT
THE FI WAYS.
MA IN HIS OWN DHS OFFICIALS ARE
GUESSTIMATING THAT THEY WILL BE
18,000 PEOPLE PER DAY TRYING TO
ENTER THE UNITED STATES.
AND RIGHT NOW WOULD LOOK IN A
7,000 TO 10,000 AND BRANDON IS
RIGHT.
AND WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE GNOME
GOT A WAYS, THESE ARE PEOPLE
THAT HAVE NOT BEEN BATTED, THIS
IS A NATIONAL SECURITY CRISIS.
NSF HUMANITARIAN CRISIS, I MEAN
WHAT WE SAW BILL MILLER SHE
REPORTED ON IS THE SAME THINGS
THAT I'VE BEEN SEEING AND HE'S
BEEN SEEING FOR THE LAST SEVERAL
YEARS.
AND NOW THAT IS GOING TO BE
DOUBLE, QUADRUPLE, TRIPLE, WE
HAD A HUNDRED AND 30,000 JUST IN
2022.
UNACCOMPANIED MINORS ENTERING
THE UNITED STATES.
A LOT OF THE STRANGE AND ABUSE,
AND SOME OF THEM ACTUALLY SOLD.
INTO THE MARKET, INTO SLAVERY,
WE SEEN WOMEN TAKEN ADVANTAGE
OF, WE SEE IN THE CARTELS AMASS
HUNDREDS OF BILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
AND THEY'VE BEEN ABLE TO BUY
SOME I AM SUBMISSIVE OF
SUBMARINES.
THE EQUIPMENTS.
WEAPONS.
THIS IS SO OUT OF CONTROL AND
THE ONLY THING, THAT THE BIDEN
POLICY IS DOING IS CREATING MORE
CHAOS IN ALLOWING THIS TO
HAPPEN.
SO YES THEY HAVE TIED THE HANDS
OF A BORDER PATROL AGENTS AND
WAS SEEN THAT OVER AND OVER
AGAIN.
IN THAT TIME THE HANDS OF OUR
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND THE FBI AND
DEA.
AND NOW WHAT WE'RE GOING TO
WITNESS AS AMERICANS IS
SOMETHING THAT WE'VE NEVER
EXPECTED TO LIVE A READY LOST A
HUNDRED THOUSAND.
A HUNDRED THOUSAND PEOPLE TO
FATTEN ALL AN OPIATE OPRAH DOES
JUST LAST YEAR ALONE.
SO IMAGINE HOW MUCH WORSE IT
WILL BE.
>> WERE GOING TO HAVE TITLE 42
PROPHECY LIFTED ONTO THE
DECEMBER 21ST.
IT ABIDED ADMINISTRATION SAYING
THEY'RE SUING THE STUMP THAT.
BUT A DHS OFFICIAL ACTUALLY
EQUATED TO BEING A GOOD TIME TO
DO IT.
BECAUSE IT IS NOT SO CLOSE TO
THE ELECTION THAT IS COMING OUT?
THE MENTALITY HERE THIS IS GOING
TO BECOME AS YOU'VE BOTH
DISCUSSED, EVEN WORSE.
AND THERE SEEMS TO BE NO EFFORT
AT ALL TO MITIGATE THIS IN ANY
FASHION.
>> PEER POLITICS.
AND WHEN YOU LOOK CURRENTLY
TAMMY, WE'RE AT, AT TIMES WE HAD
90% OF OUR RESOURCES THAT ARE
DOING A ADMINISTRATION OF
DUTIES.
DO NOT EVEN HAVE 50% OF OUR
RESOURCES TO BEGIN A SHIFT THAT
HAS BEEN ON A PORTABLE CHILD AND
THAT BY THE END OF THE SHIFT WE
HAVE TAKEN 60, 70, 80% OF OUR
RESOURCES OUT OF THE FIELD TO DO
ADMINISTRATIVE DUTIES TO DO
HOSPITAL WATCH A TRANSPORTED
PROCESSING.
THIS IS NOT WHAT IT WAS SUPPOSED
TO BE AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
SEEING THE COURT CHAOS.
>> I HAVE TO TELL YOU SARAH,
AND I THINK THIS IS THE TITLE 42
WHEN THAT GETS LIFTED IS NOTED
THAT THE EXTRA MONEY IS GOING TO
BE NEEDED IN PART TO PROCESS
SHELTER AND TRANSPORT ALL OF THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE NOW ABLE TO GET
INTO THE COUNTRY.
ONCE THAT TITLE 42 IS LIFTED.
SAID THEY ANTICIPATE THAT IT
WILL BE, EVEN THOUGH WE ARE
FIGHTING IT, BUT NOW THEY WANT
THAT MONEY TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'VE GOT THE HIGHWAY INTO THE
UNITED STATES ALL SET UP AND
COMFORTABLE FOR.
>> YEAH WE WILL BE THE LAST
LEG OF LITERALLY TRAFFICKING
HUMAN BEINGS INTO THE COUNTRY.
SO WHY SHOULD THE HUMAN
TRAFFICKERS, WHY SHOULD A DRUG
CARTEL STOPPED WHAT THEY ARE
DOING?
BECAUSE WE ARE AIDING AND
ABETTING IN THEIR NEFARIOUS
ACTION TAMMY.
AND NOT ONLY THAT THE WHO IS
GOING TO TELL THOSE CHILDREN
THAT ARE BEING SOLD IN THE
SEX TRAFFICKING THE CHILDREN
THAT ARE LOST, I'LL HAVE DIED,
THAT THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA THAT IS SUPPOSED TO
STAND ON PRINCIPLE IS ACTUALLY
AIDING AND ABETTING THE CARTELS.
THE WORST PEOPLE ON PLANET
EARTH.
AND -- >> WE HAVE INCENTIVIZE
FROM THE START THE ENTIRE
DYNAMIC WITH CHILDREN BEING
MOVED IN.
AND THEN US FACILITATING THE
MOVEMENT INTO STRANGERS
THROUGHOUT THIS COUNTRY.
IT IS, WHEN WE LOOK BACK ON THIS
AND WE WILL.
IT IS GOING TO BE HORRIFIC AND
SHOCKING.
MANY NATIONS IN THE WORLD HAVE
TO LOOK BACK ON THE HISTORIES
AND HAVE TO RECONCILE WHAT IT IS
THEY DID.
AND SOMETIMES THEY NEVER DO.
THIS IS THAT TIME.
AND OF COURSE, HOPEFULLY WILL BE
KEEPING THE REPUBLICANS AND MAKE
IT NOT